[Applause]
this is Stephen Hawking arguably the
most famous scientist of our generation
yet what if I told you that Stephen
Hawking was imprisoned for heresy fought
crimes crimes against the state
clearly this would be seemingly
ridiculous that such a thing could
happen but this is exactly what happened
to the greatest scientific genius of his
age Galileo 381 years ago Galileo was
the first person to give evidence that
we are not the only planet in our solar
system and we are not in fact the center
of the solar system nor are we the
center of the universe in fact the earth
was just one of many planets he did that
by observing the planet Jupiter and
through a very revolutionary instrument
called the refracting telescope he was
able to glimpse that Jupiter had moons
and these moons orbited not around the
earth but around Jupiter itself
this was incontrovertible proof that the
earth was not the center of the solar
system which was effectively the
universe back then he did it all with an
amazing scientific instrument a
revolutionary product that as Steve Jobs
would say just fits in your pocket the
refracting telescope this is Galileo's
four hundred and fiftieth birthday year
and tonight we're gonna throw him a
little celebration party Galileo
discovered the moons of Jupiter and in
doing so tricked our cosmic egos he
demonstrated that the earth is not the
center of it all and tonight I'm gonna
invite you to come along with me on a
journey to the very bottom of the world
a journey which has the potential
perhaps to make discoveries equal to the
discoveries that Galileo made so what
Galileo did got him into a little bit of
trouble
this is Galileo in front of the Holy
Office Holy Office is in euphemism for
the Inquisition don't you love you for
the
like this I do it's like calling the IRS
the money donation service he was
imprisoned for the remaining nine years
of his life for thought crimes and
what's amazing what he was able to do is
so amazing and revolutionary and he did
it with a simple instrument but he used
it in a powerful way and I claim this
instrument changed our understanding of
the universe more than any other
scientific instrument this is the earth
at night looking out on the Stars which
we now know are but pinpricks of light
to our eyes the two refracting
telescopes in our heads with our eyes we
can look out in space and look out in
time and we can glimpse these distant
objects we now know that these objects
represent Suns that harbours planets and
moons and these Suns are just one of
hundreds of billions in our galaxy alone
and guess what
there are hundreds of billions of
galaxies as well in the universe Galileo
unseated us as the center of it all and
with the telescope magnified if you will
to mix metaphors or in significance so
tonight will be interesting to discover
along with me is what you would see if
you had microwave eyes if you had
microwave eyes instead of seeing
pinpricks of light from stars you'd see
this magnificent tapestry that
represents the pattern of photons coming
to us from the Big Bang itself 13.8
billion years ago it's an amazing image
that captures the properties of matter
dark matter energy dark energy
throughout our entire cosmic history
with our eyes and our brains we can
attempt to make an image of the infant
universe - what can this be compared I
like to think of what would be the
earliest possible baby photograph that
you could possibly take that would be
the image this object over here so I'm a
doctor I'm not a real doctor according
to my brother's but
I still prescribe medicine no I don't do
that this is called a blastocyst it's a
collection of cells about 200 to 400
cells that represent the human embryo
roughly a thousand seconds after
conception a thousand seconds after your
own personal Big Bang
this blastocysts is an amazingly
complicated structure imagine if we were
trying to unravel what did your
blastocysts look like now I can't take a
picture of every one of you in the
audience but I can take the most famous
person on the planet our President
Barack Obama imagine if I was trying to
use this image of Barack today to get an
image of baby Barack baby Barack's
blastocyst this only represents an
extrapolation in time by a factor of a
million from two billion seconds to a
thousand seconds and yet what we're
trying to do with our instrument at the
South Pole is uncover what the universe
looked like a trillionth of a trillionth
of a trillionth of a second after the
Big Bang the so-called inflationary
universe the spark that ignited the Big
Bang inflation takes place in a vast
landscape potentially called the
multiverse in which multiple universes
could exist we're trying to take this
image of the night sky in microwaves and
transform from it an image of what the
baby universe must have looked like my
colleagues at NASA have done a wonderful
job of rendering this image as if you
are an omniscient deity looking down on
our universe and seeing it from a
distance this is the pattern that you'd
see on this beach ball this image
inspired me to unravel what caused these
colorful fluctuations what could break
the symmetry the isotropy of the early
universe filled with chaos and
randomness what could possibly be the
origin of those fluctuations is what has
driven me in my career in 2001 I pitched
an idea to my advisor at Caltech
professor Andrew Lang who believed in me
thank God because it was a crazy and
risky thing to do as a young postdoc
toiling away he said Brian this might be
the ultimate cosmic wild-goose chase but
we should do it and we did do it we
assembled an amazing team of about two
dozen scientists from around the world
led by Professor John Kovac at Harvard
University and with this amazing team we
were able to construct a beautiful
instrument that's compact yet powerful
doesn't quite fit in your pocket it's
about five feet long weighs about 10,000
pounds but Galileo would recognize it if
your pocket holds an iPhone 6 maybe it
does instead of glass lenses that
Galileo used to peer out into the
universe our telescope uses this frisbee
looking device it's a lens made of
high-density polyethylene that's nothing
more than the same material used to make
milk jugs and just as you can feel heat
or cold through a milk jug microwave
heat passes beautifully through
transparent to microwaves plastics like
this this is a simple part of our
telescope the complicated part of our
telescope which you can't buy in the
supermarket are these amazing detectors
designed by Professor challenge stands
for University and built by Jamie Bach
professor at Caltech in the Jet
Propulsion Laboratory these are the most
sensitive detectors ever made and they
are made of exotic materials that
operate near absolute zero called
superconductors with this amazing
technology we decided we needed to build
an instrument so powerful that we would
need an observatory just as good as our
telescope was powerful for microwaves if
you're looking for heat you don't want
to build a telescope here in sunny San
Diego you want to build it at the bottom
of the world Antarctica Antarctica is
the coldest driest highest continent on
earth and it's ideal for obtaining
images of the infant universe we did
build this telescope and we shipped it
down to the South Pole the South Pole
was the site of the space race of the
1919 eleven by Roald Amundsen and a
month later by Robert Scott it was the
moon race of its time and sort of like
our moon race nobody's gone back nobody
went back to the South Pole for almost
50 years I hope he'd go back to the moon
Scott's team famously perished just
seven miles away from their life-giving
pile of food and supplies tragically and
today Antarctica is still a place right
with danger
man-made and natural as this video
grainy as it is captures from my last
expedition to the South Pole
it's it's still friendlier than a lot of
faculty meetings I go to this is the
South Paul Research Station the
amundsen-scott research station at the
very bottom of the world it's built by
the National Science Foundation with
taxpayer money thank you when you get
there when you get there you have a
solemn duty to take the world's most
southern selfie and post it to
Foursquare to check in after doing this
you get to work our telescopes it's in
the second-most important building at
the South Pole called the called the
Dark Sector laboratory there it is
and if you climb to the top of the dark
sector laboratory you look down and you
peer down and you see our instrument our
baby
that's hoping to take these amazing
images of the microwave background
radiation this fanciful pattern is
rendered on the top of this image it was
taken by this gentleman here Stefan
Richter who's a man that we pay to spend
almost a full year at the South Pole why
because it's so cold you cannot get in
or out of the South Pole for almost a
year at a time this image captures
sunset which only occurs once per year
six months later the Sun comes up one
day and one night per year how do we get
someone to spend a year of their lives
at the bottom of the world it's simple
we told him we'll pay you 75 thousand
dollars tax-free and all you have to do
is work for one night
tragically just a month after we got the
data that first came out of our
telescope my advisor my friend my mentor
Andrew Lange took his own life we still
don't understand why he would do such a
thing I'm still angry at him I'm still
frustrated we miss him terribly
every day we think about him and we've
dedicated our results to his memory and
tribute what do our results look like
this image which was printed in The
Washington Post shows our real data
produced by professor Clem price of the
University of Minnesota this image shows
the swirling twisting curling pattern of
microwaves that some say indicate the
very birth of the universe a birth
called inflation our results are
powerful they're controversial though
for two reasons that I'll explain one
reason our controversial is that it may
be there are other explanations for
these images rather than just the
amazing image of the infant universe it
could be that there's dust so to speak
on the cosmic lens cap it might be that
microscopic grains of dust that look
like this greatly magnified can get
aligned by the weak magnetic fields in
our galaxy and form swirling patterns of
microwaves which can masquerade as the
pattern that we claim represents the
genesis of the Big Bang the second
controversy is more fundamental it is a
philosophical and some say theological
controversy revolves around the fact
that the multiverse theory seems to mean
that our universe is just one
potentially of an infinite number of
universes some that pop into and out of
existence every nanosecond but they're
so far away from us in this infinite
landscape called the multiverse that we
could never see them some say that this
is evidence of how special we are an
anthropomorphic
but it might be that will never be
believed until we have evidence of
another universe colliding with our own
universe not flitting and flooding out
of existence
instead some say wait till we have
evidence that we have collided with
another universe inside the multiverse
well this is pretty improbable and I
thought for Galileo's four hundred and
fiftieth birthday we throw them a little
party I'm gonna throw this beach ball
out into the audience it represents
Earth there are ten beach balls
distributed throughout this auditorium
that represents other universes in the
multiverse let's see if any of those
will collide with this gigantic earth
beast well watch out now release the
universes what would what would Galileo
my hero have to say about all of this I
think
[Applause]
I think Galileo himself the maestro
[Applause]
would be very pleased that our
discoveries made with a simple
refracting telescope have changed our
view of the universe yet again let us
thank the maestro by giving him a bigger
bicep thank you very much
you